"JUSTICE."
"STREET JUSTICE" STRAIGHT FROM
CPAC.
BUT FIRST MY OPENING STATEMENT.
THE WOMAN IS EVEN DUMBER THAN I
THOUGHT.
IT MUST BE BECAUSE SHE HAS
NOTHING ELSE TO DO.
THIS WEEK MY FAVORITE
EX-POLITICIAN HILLARY CLINTON
PUT OUT THIS TWEET.
QUOTE, I SAY THIS AS A FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE AND AS AN
AMERICAN.
THE RUSSIANS ARE STILL COMING.
OUR INTELLIGENCE PROFESSIONALS
ARE IMPLORING TRUMP TO ACT.
WILL HE CONTINUE TO IGNORE AND
SURRENDER OR PROTECT OUR
COUNTRY?
YOU ARE KIDDING, RIGHT?
DID YOU FALL ASLEEP DURING THIS
MOVIE?
>> THAT'S HOW WE GOT TO AMERICA.
>> THE RUSSIANS HAVE LANDED.
THE AIRPORT.
>> WE HAVEN'T GOT A CHANCE.
WE HAVEN'T GOT A CHANCE.
>>
JUDGE JEANINE: HILLARY, OUR
INTELLIGENCE PROFESSIONALS ARE
IMPLORING TRUMP TO ACT?
WHERE DID YOU GET THAT FROM?
YOU DON'T HAVE A SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
NOT THAT IT MATTERED WHEN I DID
HAVE ONE.
IF YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT NSA
DIRECTOR MIKE ROGERS, HE
TESTIFIED THIS WEEK OUR
GOVERNMENT WAS TAKING STEPS TO
COUNTER RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE BUT
PROBABLY NOT ENOUGH.
WHEN MUELLER INDICTED 13
RUSSIANS FOR INTERFERING IN THE
2016 ELECTION, A LOT OF CASES
WENT BACK TO 2014 AND OBAMA
SIMPLY FAILED TO ACT, THINKING
AS LONG AS IT BENEFITED YOU,
HILLARY WHY DO YOU CARE?
IF YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT PUTIN
BRAGGING AGAINST PUTIN'S
MILITARY MIGHT.
NO ONE SHOULD UNDERSTAND THAT
BETTER THAN YOU.
REMEMBER?
>> TO JUST BE GROSSLY
GENERALISTIC.
YOU COULD PUT HALF OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS INTO WHAT I WOULD
CALL THE BASKETS OF DEPLORABLES.
RIGHT?
THE RACIST, SEXIST, HOMOPHOBIC,
XENOPHOBIC, ISLAMOPHOBIC, YOU
NAME IT.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE PEOPLE
LIKE THAT.
AND HE HAS LIFTED THEM UP.
AND BY THE WAY, PUTIN HIMSELF
WASN'T MUCH HAPPY WITH YOU WHEN
YOU INTERFERED IN HIS ELECTION.
YOU AND THE DEMOCRATS USED
RUSSIA AS AN EXCUSE FOR NOT
WINNING.
SO PUTIN UNITES HIS COUNTRY BY
GOING AFTER THE COMMON ENEMY.
HILLARY, WHO DO YOU THINK YOU
ARE KIDDING?
YOU ARE THE ONE WHO DID THE
ON RAIN SHOWER COMRADE IN ARMS
HAD HIGGS FAMOUS OFF-MIC MOMENT.
>> AFTER THE ELECTION I WILL
HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY.
>> I TRANSMIT TO VLADIMIR.
JUDGE JEANINE: THE RUSSIANS HAD
MORE ACCESS TO OUR GOVERNMENT
UNDER OBAMA WHERE.
HE SAYS HE TOLD PUTIN, CUT IT
OUT.
WHEN THE RUSSIANS HACKED THE
DNC'S EMAILS, INCLUDING YOURS,
EXPOSING YOU AS A TWO-FACED LIAR
THAT YOU ARE.
YOU WOULDN'T EVEN COOPERATE WITH
THE FBI'S INVESTIGATION.
HILLARY, YOU ASK IF TRUMP WILL
CONTINUE TOO IGNORE AND
SURRENDER.
IGNORING AND SURRENDERING WAS
WHEN YOU AND BILL SOLD 0% OF OUR
NATIONAL RESOURCE URANIUM TO THE
RUSSIANS WITH A PAYBACK OF $145
MILLION TO YOUR FOUNDATION AND
$500,000 IN YOUR HUBBY'S POCKET.
YOU SOLD ONE OF OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES USED TO MAKE MOLLY 99
USED TO TREAT CANCER PATIENTS.
UNLIKE YOU AND BILL, DONALD
TRUMP CAN'T BE BOUGHT.
AND YOU ASK, WILL THE PRESIDENT
PRO ACCOUNT OUR COUNTRY?
HE'S NOT LIKE YOUR PHILANDERING
HUSBAND WHO CAME BILLIONS TO KIM
JONG-UN'S DAUGHTER TO NOT BUILD
A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
THAT WORKED OUT REALLY WELL NOW
DIDN'T IT.
DONE WHERE IS THE ONLY PRESIDENT
WITH THE GUTS TO NOT ONLY SEND
THE MOTHER OF ALL BOMBS INTO
AFGHANISTAN, STOP THE CHEMICAL
WEAPONS PLAN IN SYRIA WITH
SURGICAL PRECISION AND GO TOE TO
TOE WITH KIM JONG-UN WHERE THAT
WHACK-A-DO IS A LAUGHINGSTOCK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMMITTED $700
BILLION TO REBUILD OUR ARMED
FORCES SO WE CAN PROTECT THE
COUNTRY THROUGHOUT, YOUR
HUSBAND, AND YOUR COMRADE BARACK
MADE MORE VULNERABLE.
IF YOU ARE SO CONVINCED THE
RUSSIANS ARE STILL COMING, WHY
DIDN'T YOU DO SOMETHING BY THE
WHEN YOU WERE IN OFFICE?
HILLARY, IT'S GOT TO BE TOUGH
BEING YOU.
YOU USE ALL THE MONEY YOU
ILLEGALLY TOOK FROM FOREIGN
POWERS TO CREATE A FALSE DOSSIER
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
YOU GOT FED DEBATE QUESTIONS.
DELETED 33,000 EMAILS, YET YOU
STILL LOST TO SOMEONE YOU SAY
ISN'T FIT TO BE PRESIDENT.
I HAVE GOT AN IDEA.
SINCE YOU ARE SO GOOD AT SELLING
OUR RAIN YUMG TO OUR ENEMIES.
MAYBE YOU CAN BUDDY UP WITH THE
REST YOUR FRIENDS TO SELL THE
REST OUR URANIUM TO RUSSIA.